all right first thing that I hate I
meant to do this last week now I have to
do it there is a video that came out
showing professional cuddling I talked
about a little bit but I need to
actually show you the video of the
professional cuddling this is just
horrendous and never should happen in
the planet these are people who are
being hired to cuddle with other people
like strangers it says this person is a
total stranger to me her job is to give
people cuddles she's a professional cut
list touch more likely than not they're
not getting the level of touch that they
need in their everyday life I'm just
about to go for my very first company
session and personally I have been going
through a tough time lately so I'm very
curious to see if that session will help
me in any way this is the session that
starts by setting some ground rules she
asked you to think about what you're
most comfortable with as a first timer
becoming relaxed wasn't easy because why
do you have a stranger's says how would
you like me to join you and she's like
um I wouldn't says I had to rely on this
cuddle Sutra book for inspiration okay
okay oh no yes it's pretty awkward okay
then this goes on it gets better with
time though why would you why why why
why why sorry what yeah
okay so we're living in the society were
worried about sexual harassment and
sexual abuse you hire a professional cut
list a Rando to come over your house and
they're professional what makes you a
professional Cutlass like what makes you
good at this I'm just wondering do you
go to Cutlass school you get a PhD in
cuddling and what in the what in the
actual F they get a boyfriend you know
get it get a dog like seriously people
you know what's happened we've sozin
we've so much separated sex and touch
from from emotion that now we're trying
to reach those things back together but
without actually forming emotional
connection with the person you have to
hire the person nor to cuddle you I mean
like when guys do used to do this it was
called a whorehouse when women do it
with other women then it's just cuddling
means there's nothing sexual going on I
guess but it's like it's a random person
that you're hugging like what in the
world and then we're gonna need a tough
enough gang I think we're gonna need to
have enough I'm not sure Western
civilization can survive the onslaught
of reality if you're hiring people to
lie next to you and cuddle you who you
don't know what in the world okay